welcome back to the David Pakman show. It's
great to welcome to the program today. Tom
Wheeler, who is the former chairman of the
FCC Federal Communications Commission.
Uh, thanks so much for talking to me today,
David. Great to be with you. So I mean, to
begin with, I think if we want to have a conversation
about what regulation of tech companies should
look like, it's important to understand how
we sort of got to where we are. So maybe to
start with, how have tech companies relatively
successfully avoided the type of regulation
that some believe it should be in place?
Well, you know, David, um, it's interesting.
I have a new book out called from Gutenberg
to Google the history of our future. And one
of the things it talks about is how every
time a new technology comes along, um, it's
the innovators that make the rules. And, um,
and that's the situation that we're in now.
You know, it was the same story, whether it
was, um, uh, the pioneers who were pioneering
the west or a, or a a Rockefeller. And Carnegie
because they see the vision, they make the
rules, and they make the rules until such
time as those decisions begin to impact on
the rights of others and the public interest.
And I think that's where we are today. And
so it's time for us, the people through our
elected representatives to take back the rulemaking
and the decide what are the rules that are
in the public interest, not just the interests
of the pioneers.
Yeah, I mean, of course I agree with you.
I don't think it'll come as a shock to my
audience that I do, but the issue that we've
had historically, particularly in the last
couple of decades, is that because the desires
of large corporations and the wealthy are
much more likely to be made into what becomes
the regulatory environment, what makes the
priorities of the House and Senate, um, and,
and it's turned into bills. What, what is
it that the average person can actually do
to make sure that what's in the public's best
interest is done? I mean, look at, look at
the net neutrality situation, right? At millions
and millions of comments. The FCC website
going down, et Cetera, et cetera. You know,
the story of my audience knows the story.
And we've got to repeal of net neutrality
as an example. So Ken, Ken, what's in the
public interest really be successfully lobbied
for by the public?
Well, yes, and, and the, the, the, the reality
there is if you don't, who will? Okay. So
I mean, so you can say, oh my goodness, I'm
just, uh, individual, um, I don't count. Um,
well then you might as well turn it over,
um, to, uh, the folks who are running the
big companies. Um, and, and I wouldn't say
by the way that the net neutrality fight is
over. No, it's not what we're in. We're in
court right now challenging the, the ridiculousness
of the Trump fccs repeal of the rules. Um,
and I think I'm cautiously optimistic about
that. And then the house of Representatives
passed a piece of legislation that, um, that
reinstates the rules. So that, that's very
much, um, in play. And, um, and what we can't
fall prey to is, um, uh, demand that everything
has to happen quickly. This is a, this is
a long game.
There's no question. It's a game. And one
of the players that wants to have a say in
that game in terms of the regulation is the
tech companies themselves. And we've seen
more and more companies say, oh, we are forming.
We saw Zuckerberg say it in, in testimony
under oath and others, I believe regulation
is a good thing and I want to work with our
elected officials to get the, the regulation
in place. Is this something that we should
have any, uh, do you believe that this is
a good faith offer that tech companies are
making to participate in figuring out what
the regulations should be? Or is it just the,
the, the Fox guarding the Hen House? Well,
I don't think it's bad faith, but I think
that it is a situation of where you stand
depends on where you sit. And you know, when
I was chairman of the FCC, people would always
come in and say, Oh, let me tell you why.
What is in my interest is in the public interest.
And, um, and they would define things very
narrowly. And what we're seeing right now
are, are the tech companies saying, okay,
you know, for instance, I'm for net neutrality,
but I'm for, uh, that definition of net neutrality
being an empty bag, if you will.
When it comes to the reality that many of
these platforms are both social network content
providers and they are also massive ad brokerage
platforms, do you believe that those two sides
of many of these entities need to be separated
either via antitrust or some other means?
Well, of course, that's the kind of issue
that Elizabeth Warren and others, uh, have
been, have been making. And I've got a lot
of respect for that. I have some concern that,
um, you know, you gotta love it when your
cell phone is off the list.
Someone does not want you to tell me what
your view is on the end
trust issue. Very clearly. They, yeah, but
we've solved that problem. The, uh, but, but
you know, you've got to look at the antitrust
is really three prongs. Yes. First, the first
prong is, um, is to break up the companies.
Um, the difficulty there is it's a, it's a
long prong. You know, it was, it was 10 years
between, um, the filing of the suit to break
up a t and t and the actual breakup of a t
and t. Um, and, and so that's a serious challenge.
And we also have a problem that our supreme
court right now, um, is, um, holds to the
Chicago school theory, um, that makes it very
difficult to establish arm. The second prong
of antitrust enforcement, um, is regulatory.
Um, and that's what I tried to do a at the
FCC and to take competitive principles and
put them into regulation. And the third prong
is this concept of openness that you and I
were just talking about. Um, and, and so I
think it would be an interesting concept if
rather than just talking about, um, separating
the social platform from the ad sales activity,
we go right to the heart of what is it that
creates the market dominance in both of those
areas. And that's their data. And if we're
talking about our networks being open, that
we probably ought to be talking about the
services that use our network.
And in so doing capture our personal information
then making that information also in your
connectable just like that at works are. So
just to be clear, is that an issue of privacy
regulation? Is that an issue of data ownership?
No, I think it's an issue of two things. It
goes back to the old common law concept, um,
of a, of the duty to deal. You can't hoard
information, uh, any more than the guy who
was running the ferry across the river to
tell somebody that he couldn't ride on the
ferry. And then there's also a duty of care,
which is, okay, I've got your information,
I've got a fiduciary responsibility to you
as to how I'm going to deal with that information
and, and we need to go to get at both of those.
And if you deal with that, then you're dealing
with the core issue that creates this monopoly
power elsewhere. So
in the European Union there is now the general
data protection regulation, Gdpr and it does
a lot of different things. One of the, one
of the issues is it goes to the sort of like
the financial risk to internet companies for
improperly sharing user data. It imposes a
large fines. Hypothetically, do you like that
framework? Is there, does it not go far enough?
Maybe, does it go too far?
No, I thought Gdpr was a great first step.
Um, uh, I'm not sure it can be, uh, imported
wholesale a into the United States because
of some of our laws and traditions. But it,
it, it established the principle that there
was a responsibility to the party that was
collecting the data. Um, and, but let me use
another European, um, uh, example that that
kind of supports the openness principal I
was just talking about. And that is that in
the UK, um, the government has required that
the nine largest bank
open up or make open access available with
consumer permission, um, the data that they
hold on consumers so that third parties can
offer innovative new services to those consumers
that the services wouldn't be available previously
because they didn't have access to the data
and the companies, the banks were hoarding
that data and say, well, you can only buy
our services. And now they were forced to
open it up. And there are 200 different service
providers that have sprung up saying, Hey,
I've got a competitive way of a competitive
alternative, uh, for consumers to, to consider.
I think we can bring that kind of attitude
of the United States.
Yeah. I mean that's interesting because that's
a very market ish sort of solution, which
is not to say we need to, uh, make it so that
the data is not being shared in the first
place or if it's not dealing so much with
what some, see as the problem of this data
being a marketable commodity. But it's saying
let's level the playing field and letting
that data hypothetically at least be used
to create other things of value. So I'm not
making a value judgment necessarily, but it's
certainly a solution that says we want more
sort of free market, um, uh, possibilities
rather than a consumer protection angle. Is
that, am I interpreting that correctly or
not?
It goes back, it goes back to the concept
David of openness and interconnected interconnection.
I mean the, the concept behind net neutrality
was open networks. Now let's talk about how
we have open data, um, that has been collected
through the use of those networks. And we
make that data available to spur competition,
to talk a little bit about the next four to
eight years or you know, the next political
cycle so to speak. And, and what, uh, it will
happen in terms of both net neutrality and
also tech regulation that we're talking about.
What are the, um, elements of government that
are going to most determine the path forward?
Is it as simple as if Trump gets reelected?
Not much will change at the FCC. If a Democrat
wins, things will change. Is it elsewhere?
We should be looking.
Well, I think you could make that kind of
a, of a, of a simple converse. And I mean,
you, you, you, you look at, you know, what
the Trump administration has done thus far,
you know, it has been to tear everything down.
I mean, what does the Trump FCC done? They've
gone through and systematically eliminated,
um, whatever they can. And, but, but there's
an interesting thing that's happening as a
result of that, David. Um, and that is that
the tech companies have perhaps been too successful.
They have, they have, they have convinced
the federal government, particularly the Trump
administration, to totally leave them alone.
And in that kind of avoid, they invite others,
whether it is states like California stepping
into pass laws on, uh, on privacy and net
neutrality, 36 other states that have stepped
up to do something about net neutrality or
countries. You mentioned Gdpr a minute ago
and other things that are happening, uh, in
the EU.
And all of a sudden that companies are waking
up and saying, oh my golly, wait a minute.
You know, w we don't have anybody establishing
a common set of rules. And so we've got 36
different states doing things with net neutrality.
Golly, I'd feel a lot better if there was
only one rule. And so the fact that they did
everything possible to kill meaningful net
neutrality at the federal level has opened
them up at the state level. The fact that
they have done everything possible to kill
meaningful privacy regulation. I mean we put
the first network privacy requirements in
place. Uh, when I was at the FCC and 67 days
after the Trump administration came into office
that the Republican Congress repealed them.
And now all at the request of the companies
and now the companies are seeing California
and other states and countries pop up with
their own set of rules that are saying, oh
my golly, I can't have all these different
rules out there. I got to have one set of
rules. And so it may be, um, uh, you know,
there, there's a great Oscar Wilde quote.
He said that he said that, uh, there are two
tragedies in life not getting what you want.
And getting it. And the reality here is the
tech companies just may have been so massively
successful that they have forced themselves
to, uh, embrace, um, a federal regulation
that here to, for they and always been opposing.
We will, uh, of course continue to follow
it. It could go a number of different ways.
As you are outlining, we've been speaking
with former chairman of the FCC Tom Wheeler.
I will mention his book, which was published,
uh, February 26th from Gutenberg to Google
the history of our future. Such a pleasure
having you on. Thanks David and Jordan